tras dos años de pandemia colombia va a
las urnas en 2020 con la expansión del
coi 19 por el país las autoridades
tomaron medidas drásticas para
contrarrestar sus efectos en la economía
pero la crisis sanitaria dejó cicatrices
miles de empresas cerraron y las ayudas
del gobierno de iván to que fueron
insuficientes el tema de la pandemia
sinceramente nos tiene muy muy mal a
todo el comercio en realidad terrible la
verdad las ventas de nada han bajado
demasiado
un 100 por ciento yo diría pues en ambas
a mí personalmente un 80 por ciento en
2020 el producto interno bruto de
colombia se contrajo en un 7 por ciento
una reducción histórica mientras que en
2021 el crecimiento económico según el
gobierno fue del 10 6% ese dato
macroeconómico contrasta con cifras
preocupantes el número de personas en
situación de pobreza supera los 21
millones tres millones y medio más que
antes de la pandemia según proyecciones
de la organización para la cooperación y
el desarrollo económico colombia
cerraría 2022 con un desempleo del 11 8%
es el nivel de recuperación del año
pasado fue el rebote
después de un año muy malo que fue el
año 2020 es una recuperación donde
esencialmente
aumentó la demanda
producto de los apoyos que dio el
gobierno producto de que también las
personas salieron a la calle y
finalmente volvieron a abrir la economía
y se reactivaron las ventas y se
reactivó la producción pero
desafortunadamente sin empleo entonces
por eso no es tan sostenible la
polarización será otro gran protagonista
de las elecciones ésta no sólo sigue
expresándose con fuerza en torno a los
acuerdos de paz que llevaron a la
desmovilización de la guerrilla de las
farc hay además abismos ideológicos
entre la izquierda agrupada en el
denominado pacto histórico liderado por
el ex congresista gustavo petro y las
fuerzas de la derecha que defienden al
impopular gobierno de guandú que aunque
algunos analistas opinan que el problema
es otro si hay un problema cuando
contienda electoral presidencial es que
hay demasiados candidatos y la gente lo
que está es perdida tratando de tomar
decisiones entre un mar de opciones que
no se diferencia mucho y que no logran
destacar inciertos también si las
grandes movilizaciones del paro nacional
que comenzaron justo antes de la
pandemia tendrán algún impacto electoral
en especial entre los jóvenes que fueron
sus protagonistas